حاكم مقاطعه روسيا المتاخمه للحدود
الاوكرانيه مقتل مدنيا واصابه طفل بجروحه
وذلك في اطلاق النار نفذتهما وصفها
بمجموعه تخريبيه اوكرانيه تسللت للمقاطعه
واحتاجزت عددا من الرهائن في متجر ومنازل
في قريه
وقد نقلت وكاله رايانوفوستي عن الكرملين
ان الرئيس الروسي الغى زيارته المجدوله
اليوم الاقليمي
اجتماعا طارئا لمجلس الامن الروسي يناقش
الوضع فيبرياسك
وقد ندد رئيس روزي فلاديمير بوتين بالهجوم
في برياس واعتبره ارهابي وقال بوتين في
كلمه متلفزه ان الجيش الروسي يحمي روسيا
وشعبها ممن وصفهم بالنازيين الجدد
والارهابيين الذين تسللوا الى الاراضي
الروسيه وفتحوا النار على مدنيين على حد
تعبيره
هذا ونشرت وسائل تواصل اجتماعي صور قالت
انها لوحدات روسيه تطلق على نفسها اسم
الفيلق الروسيه التطوعي وتتبع القوات
الاوكرانيه وقال المسلحون في المقطع انه
موجودون في قريه
لتحرير ارضهم داعين في الوقت نفسه لحمل
سلاحه واعلان العصيان ضد السلطات الروسيه
في الروايه المقابله قالت المخابرات
الاوكرانيه ان المعلومات حول ما وصفته
بالاصطدام في منطقه هي استمرار للتحول في
روسيا
وتحريرها وتنقيتها من ديكتاتوريه بوتين
على حسب تعبيرها في الاثناء وصف المتحدث
باسم الاداره العسكريه لمقاطعه اوديسا في
اوكرانيا
روسيه بشان برياسك بانها محض اكاذيب
من يقف وراء الاحداث في منطقه بريانس اذا
ثبت حدوثها بالفعل هذه استمرار لحمله
الاكاذيب والتضليل الروسيه لماذا لا تكون
الروايه هي ان مرتزقه وسجناء هم من قاموا
بهذا العرض الاستفزازي او ان تكون الروايه
الاخرى هي ان مجموعه من الاستخبارات
الروسيه قد ارتدت الزير الاوكراني ووضعت
شعارات صفراء واختلقت بعض الوثائق ودعت
انها اوكرانيا